los ocupantes intentan reforzar aún más
la presión en el tumbas es un infierno y
no es una exageración los bombardeos
sobre severodonezk son brutales y sin
sentido sigue órdenes que la ofensiva
rusia sobre el donbass cada vez es más
potente lo advierte el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski y lo
reitera el gobernador de la región de
lugansk quien informó de 13 muertes en
las últimas 24 horas 12 de ellas en un
ataque ruso repelido en la ciudad de
severodonezk rusia entretanto asegura
que tiene casi el control total de la
región y acusa a ucrania de utilizar a
los civiles como escudos humanos
la liberación de la república popular de
lugansk está a punto de completarse las
fuerzas armadas de ucrania tratando de
retrasar los movimientos de las tropas
rusas no dejan salir a los residentes
locales de las ciudades y pueblos y los
utilizan como escudos humanos
la otra gran ofensiva rusia la librada
en la planta de azotes tal prosigue
también su marcha
el kremlin asegura que allí ya se han
rendido casi 2.000 soldados ucranianos
mientras comandantes del batallón asoc
siguen dentro de la planta y aseguran
que la misión era evacuar heridos y
salvar las vidas de los soldados wisco
walker y el alto mando militar ha dado
la orden de salvar la vida y la salud de
los militares de la guarnición y dejar
de defender la ciudad a pesar de los
intensos combates la defensa del
perímetro y la ausencia de suministros
hemos insistido en las tres variables
más importantes para nosotros civiles
heridos y muertos entonces rible el
grueso de los combatientes que
depusieron las armas está siendo
trasladado por el ejército ruso hacia
una antigua colonia penal cerca de
dónetsk